[Music]
well i can't dance like you but i might
make you try to teach me one movie we'll
test that i'm sorry yeah i'm sure you
got some mode i'm sure you got some
moves
did not wear the right shoes for this
i wasn't the only one who got a dance
lesson from mega entertainers twitch and
alison we teamed up with the duo and dsg
to surprise a deserving school
we were so excited to be able to reach
these kids and share in a special dance
with them it was the kids dance outreach
and we also were able to surprise them
with a 50 000
sports matter grant on behalf of the
sporting goods foundation so it was just
a really special moment where we got to
dance with them we want to celebrate
with them and just get to know them
better we would like to present you with
the 50 000 sports model grant
[Applause]
what's great about this too they're
using that money to actually create
their dance space right because
obviously you know their their goal is
to provide like high quality dance
education to like kids that need it so
you also need a space to do that too and
kids dance outreach is just doing so
much in indianapolis they're giving back
to so many kids so now we want to like
show them that they have support now
from you know us in the community it's
that thing of like um
being someone that you wish you had when
you were growing up do you know what i'm
saying and providing those kind of
opportunities that you wish you had when
you're growing up you know that is like
the definition of success it really is
absolutely 100 because i guess nothing
feels better you know what i mean so you
guys are wearing the dsg apparel ring oh
yes oh shut up oh no honestly we love it
because they're also like a very
inclusive brand it's about making it
accessible for all athletes right
literally whether you're a dancer or a
baseball player basketball player
anybody like and listen right now if
music were to come on i'm ready to bust
a move at any point okay right like i'm
always ready can we get a little arm
choreo right now like literally what
we can kiss boom give me some of that
right there
[Music]